I'm not surprised.
I want to thank you because what was
surprising about your electric today?
It was his concept of altruism.
I think you've been able to just put
everything together and at the end come
with a higher value of altruism.
And to me it was a surprise.
You don't come in here and
I have a relationship with
altruism and the one that
I find it's difficult for me is that
there's an evolutionary process of my
brain.
It's an organ is developed,
you know,
and,
and I'm amazed at how often
I think of three people,
me and myself and I to the point where
where I've actually written down counter
all of the iterations of me,
myself and I and either my thoughts or
my speech or even in someone else's and
you'll get a page and saw them do we
think of wheat as far as I've been able to
ascertain is because I have to expend
energy to think about someone else.
And,
and,
and yet yet I'm addicted to ease and
comfort because my natural evolution is
going to be some comfort.
And you hear it in,
in alcoholics anonymous.
Well,
booze ain't the problem.
You're addicted to ease and comfort.
How do I overcome my,
what I think is my sense of ease and
comfort to be able to make altruism
a more natural state of being good.
Good,
good question.
So the question is,
the first was a comment about the emphasis
in my talk today on altruism in the
second is how do I,
how do people overcome their proclivity
to only act on their own behalf?
Okay.
So the first thing I will say is that
I don't believe that what I spoke about
today was in favor of altruism.
And and I,
that's not a negative
comment on your question,
but there,
so there's a,
there's,
there's a pro,
here's a primary religious injunction.
Treat the other person like you
would like to be treated yourself.
That does not mean be
nice to other people.
It does not mean sacrifice
yourself excessively for
other people it means think
about the other person has,
if they were you,
and figure out how you can mutually
interacts to better both of you.
At the same time you have to
build yourself into the equation.
It's an equation.
It's not that.
It's not that the others
are more valuable,
it's that we're all valuable,
were equally valuable.
And then you think,
well how do you remind yourself of that?
And the answer to that is through
terror because terror is the genuine
motivator.
So they save
fear of God is the
beginning of all wisdom.
Well what does that mean?
It means first that you
don't get away with anything.
And it's really useful to know that
because if you really know that you won't
try to get away with while you still
will because people are stupid but,
but at least it will
mitigate the possibility.
So here,
I'll tell you something that young said,
this is quite,
this is quite profound and,
and it's,
I think the right answer to this question.
So young believed he was interested
in the emergence of higher morality.
Uh,
something that the
developmental psychologist,
Sean Piaget was also interested in.
Here's a thought.
We started out as individuals.
Then we learned to play
games with other people,
kids,
children learn how to play
games without the children.
And that made them social.
So our society is a game.
It's a giant game that we're all
playing together voluntarily.
And so children were first
learned how to play the game,
and only later did they
learn the rules of the game.
And he learned how to play the game
first and then learn the rules to how to
speak the rules.
And then at some point they realized that
they were also creators of the rules.
And so that's moral development
on a continual on a,
it's not a continuum,
it's,
it's a fractured staircase upward.
But young was interested in elements of
moral action that were higher than that.
And so he conceptualized it symbolically.
So imagine this,
you did this in the last book he
wrote called mysterium connectionists.
So imagine that you're exist so that
your conceptual structures and your
emotions are an uneasy
relationship with one another.
So you're sort of a house
divided amongst yourself.
And so what you have to do is you have
to put together your mind and your,
and your emotion so that
they're working as a,
as a unit.
And you do that in part by actually being
forthright about what it is that you
want for yourself and to other people.
And to learn how to negotiate that.
So that inner tension disappears.
And so now you're a unified,
you're a unified entity of emotion and
thought they're not conflicting with one
another.
And then what you do is
you take that entity,
which is still in some sense separate
from your body because you're not acting
these out and you bring
those two together.
And he thought about
that as the psychological
equivalent of the incarnation
had.
So it's integrated spirit
integrating with the body.
And what that means is that you take your
emotions and motivations and capacity
for thinking that are now one thing
and you act out those things you.
So you embodied them in the world.
And that's another thing
that brings integrity.
And then there was a step past out in
the step past that is to understand that
there's no deal.
So you have the integrated spirit,
mind and body
in opposition to the world.
And this,
the next thing you do is realize that
there is no opposition with the world.
Is that what you are as a,
and this is very,
very complicated.
You're walking down the street.
[inaudible] street is a good example of
this in Toronto and they're decimated
alcoholic,
schizophrenia.
It's littering the landscape so to speak.
You walk around them,
you say,
well,
that's not me.
It's like,
yes it is.
It's you in so far as your tendency is
to react in a negative way and to skirt
the territory.
It's,
it's a disturbance in your field of being.
It's you now,
you don't know what to do about it and I
wouldn't recommend that you do anything
because you'd probably just make it worse.
It's a very big problem that's
lying there on the sidewalk.
And it may be well beyond
your capacity to fix it.
But in so far as it's a
disturbance in your field of being,
it's you,
it's you and all the problems
that are in the world that,
that you experienced there you,
and so you stop thinking about things
in terms of an opposition between what's
good for you and what's good for the
world because there is no difference.
There's no difference between the two.
And that that doesn't mean that the
pathway from what's good for you in your
more limited domain to what's good for
everyone is an easy one to compute.
It's very,
very difficult.
But there is no,
there is no technical
difference between them,
you know?
So if I'm engaged in a psychotherapeutic
dialogue with my clients when I'm doing
it properly,
it's not like they're learning from me.
It's that we're learning together.
And every time I solved one of their
problems or help them solve one of their
problems,
I help myself solve one of my problems.
You know,
because people bring to me,
bring into my sessions the terrible
things that go wrong with people in life.
Their partner has cancer,
their father's hasn't,
father has Alzheimer's,
they're suffering with alcoholism.
Their career is collapsing.
Like these aren't things
that are happening to them.
These are things that happen to everyone.
And to figure out how to solve that for
someone is to figure out how to solve it
for yourself.
There's no difference whatsoever.
And so,
and then so there's to know that,
to,
to think of that and certainly works in,
in an intimate relationship.
If you think that you're somehow
different than your wife,
while certain she's going to
remind you otherwise constantly.
But it's an,
it's an error.
It's an error because you're,
you're tied together so tightly that
whatever happens to one inevitably happens
to the other.
And that's true in,
in the network reality
that we all inhabit.
So then the,
the terror thing emerges when you start
to realize that those problems that you
don't address that or may be magnified
by your impulsive and foolishly self
centered and instrumental behavior,
you're manipulating the world on
behalf of your own narrow interests.
Those,
we'll come back to haunt you.
And so it's a terrifying
thing to think through.
But once you think through
it and understand it,
then what happens is you're
more afraid of acting selfishly,
then you are willing to do it.
You think,
no,
I'm not doing that.
Why?
Because I know all hell will break loose
if I do that and I'm not going there.
And so the terror element has a huge one.
It makes it,
it,
it fortifies your cause you can't just act
properly.
You don't have the moral
fortitude for that.
You can aim at the good and
run from what's terrible,
then you're,
then you're motivated.
So
with your environment,
uh,
reaching out to your environment,
doesn't it,
that expenditure of energy
rather as an investment?
Yes.
It's an investment.
That's a very good way of putting it.
Yes.